we have this story from the Daily Mail
he would never do such a thing Trump
posts photo of Ron DeSantis as a teacher
allegedly partying with high school
girls as he ramps up attacks on
Republican rival ah you see now I
understand what's going on now I
understand someone someone said to me
why is it that so much fighting is
happening right now on the right why you
know Stephen Crowder daily wire thing
was the biggest version of this now you
have this it's it's primary season for
the GOP Republicans are going to go to
war and then you know what I really love
about this is when Donald Trump called
Ted Cruz lying Ted and then afterwards
the Trump supporters called them lion
Ted like Roar lion like ex excellent 180
degree thing you know now that we've
decided who's the alpha of the of the
GOP and gonna lead it and it's Trump now
we can all set aside all our differences
so take a look at this this image Donald
Trump says no way dong Chan Lee says
Rhonda Santos was having a drink party
with students when he was a high school
teacher having drinks with underage
girls and cuddling with them certainly
looks pretty ghost gross and a febophile
a febophilia-esque that's that's an
interesting choice of War that's a
that's a word so uh right off the tongue
rolls right off the tongue is this real
former president Trump posted this yeah
okay we get it and he didn't really
posted he re-shared something that
someone else right oh I'm sorry I don't
know the technical lingo for your kids
cool social medias how are we supposed
to verify this this is a blurred photo
of people standing around in a cropped
location from a guy who apparently it
doesn't even look like Ron De Santa
that's what I'm saying yeah does he have
a brother like
we were we were trying to decide whether
to title The Stream State of the Union
watch party I'm like but it's not for an
hour it's like well I guess we'll go
with Donald Trump accuses this ends up
being a groomer look at this photo
doesn't it break your heart they used to
be such good friends excuse me buddies a
febophilia by the way is paraphilia
characterized by sexual attraction to
adolescents aged from 15 to 18. there's
a word for it it's that was that common
I guess at some point it looks like some
Greek thing crazy I just don't really
get the outrage here because you know
this is this is Trump right this is who
he is he attacks the conservatives that
we love
um he's you know for lack of a better
word a ship poster and that's what
people love him for he's a fighter um so
of course he's going to go after his
competition right who wouldn't is that
like a tactic I mean you don't have to
reveal the secrecy of the the campaigns
but would he like be like all right this
week we gotta find somebody to go I mean
no I don't think it's a traditional
tactic in politics right you would never
want your candidate to post something
like this but that's why Trump I think
was able to be so successful because
he's not your typical politician right
right he's able to kind of go outside of
what you know the system has been doing
for years and break out of it and be an
outsider and a fighter and that's why
people like him right because we talked
about the price of eggs on this show
people are fired up and they want to see
someone who's angry and taking punches
but this isn't really like a strong
punch from Trump right there's no
corroborating evidence it's like when he
came out with the nickname Ron de
sanctimonious like it's not as good as
lying Ted Cruz you know what I mean like
this is I am totally neutral in this
battle but this is not his best attack
at at Rhonda Sanders especially for
people who feel strongly about these
issues right like grooming teenage girls
is not a small accusation right and I
know he didn't post it himself but to be
like well I don't know here's a blurred
photo that no one can corroborate like
it's it's it's not the fierce ferocious
social media using Donald Trump that
people fell in love with you know what
I'm saying he still serves a pot though
right that's always kind of been him um
but yeah I mean the the reality is we
won't know anything until these two get
on a debate stage DeSantis hasn't even
formally announced so we don't want to
jump the gun there are a ton of people
you know that we thought going into 2016
would totally outshine Trump and wound
up being the opposite so until we get
these guys going toe-to-toe on a debate
stage in front of the American people I
think it's just too early to kind of
cast ballots here that's a good point we
have this Twitter thread from Pedro El
Gonzalez which I I think is interesting
and I'd love to hear your rebuttal he
says Trump who is friends with Jeff
Epstein suggests DeSantis as a groomer
he will lose to Biden at this rate his
campaign is fundamentally unserious and
based on his insecurities Trump isn't
driving the movement he's just
constantly reacting to and whining about
DeSantis the first thing I'll say to
that because there's a bigger threat
here is the Trump friends with Epstein
thing is a nonsensical low blow and it's
just like sure but Donald Trump implying
Santa's groomer is also the same garbage
is this what we have to look forward to
because I I think interestingly someone
mentions in this thread or it might be
Patron self
is this the demeanor of a man or someone
asks does any of this actually matter if
Mass mail-in voting Universal mail and
voting is what determines the winner in
the end and then pager I think responds
is Trump the kind of guy was the
demeanor to actually stand up to this
deeply corrupted machine and and fix it
yeah no it's a great question I think
honestly Pedro brings up a super
accurate and needed Point Trump has
completely deviated from what got him
his win in 2016 right he's totally
abandoned and he started to abandon that
you know messaging in 2020. he's
abandoned the base in many ways he's out
there he's pushing the vax
um he's not talking about issues that
matter to the American people you know
there's no build the wall onshore jobs
rhetoric that there was in 16 so we
really have to you know I think if the
Trump campaign wants to get serious it's
time to buckle up and really bring back
that you know populist economic
nationalist message that was so popular
in 16. but it but if he's not then maybe
he's not the guy right but also maybe
it's not too late I mean it is early
yeah I mean campaigns can be won in the
very end remember that tweet where
Donald Trump was smack talking Coke and
then what did he say he said he said
something and then Coke got mad terrible
and he's like don't worry I'm still
drinking this no no but that's the
second one he said something Coke got
mad and then he said Coco Cole's not
very happy with me but don't worry I'll
still keep drinking that garbage that
was funny like that was Trump you know
and then when he starts running for
office he brought that kind of energy of
like
it was a kind of raw honesty I guess
where he wasn't sugar-coating it he's
not gonna come out just be like I
shouldn't have tweeted about Coca-Cola
I'm so sorry I won't do it and I was
like that's garbage but I'll drink it
anyway and everyone laughs like this is
good because they can identify with that
right there are so many people have bad
values they know it's literally terrible
for you and they're like but doesn't
matter I'll buy it tomorrow I went to uh
we were at the grocery store the other
day and I saw Pearl Milling Company
breakfast syrup or whatever it used to
be Aunt Jemima and then on the bottle it
says formerly Aunt Jemima new name same
Great Taste and I I thought two things
one is it still says Aunt Jemima on the
bottle they I don't understand her off
right they got rid of her put the name
still down on the bottom so you can
still see it you know what it is and
then the other funny thing was I turned
it around took a picture of the
ingredients and I'm like same great
recipe and the recipe is high fructose
corn syrup like it's just total garbage
not real maple syrup but I'm just that's
a funny Point like everybody knows Coke
is bad but they can relate to it like
I'm drinking it anyway no but but Trump
called Rosie O'Donnell what did he call
her a fat pig it sounds like him all
right called stormy Daniel's horse face
yeah I mean he is like this weirdly
vicious like elder man and middle school
girl rolled into one when he's at his
Prime and he's entertaining because he
sets the tone he sets The Narrative what
bothers me about these kinds of posting
is like it isn't posting it's just
sort of complaining and also maybe
showing that you are afraid of Rhonda
santis right like it's not Trump telling
when Trump decided that we were going to
talk about border security in the
country he made it a part of his
platform and he changed National
politics right he made people focus on
something they didn't want to talk about
before and that's not what's happening
here it's not that he couldn't do it
it's why have you announced so early if
you're not going to take command of the
race right and also why is this still on
truth you know like he should be on
every platform pumping his content so
it's reaching everybody to just post
stuff like this on truth is stupid I I
didn't someone tell us he had a contract
because the launch of truth that he he
has to give them an exclusive for a
certain amount of time or something yeah
but I mean like so what like break the
contract right are you serious about
running and like saving the country uh
that's why I don't know if Trump's the
guy I mean he was I mean look I vote I
liked him in 2020. uh his his policy
proposals no CRT and government
contracts was was great school choice he
was it seemed like his guys were really
listening and they were talking about
culture War issues but from a from a an
actual policy standpoint like saying hey
we're not going to allow critical race
Theory and gender ideology trainings in
government contracts they violate the
law it's a very academic and policy uh
way of describing our opposition to
weird wokeness stuff
now uh so so I like that in 2016 it was
a little bit too wild for me but I got
proven wrong I think when things started
getting better he actually did a good
job despite the fact that he had the
Deep state that he had these these
elements of the establishment weighing
him down I wonder how good things really
would have gotten if he wasn't being
bogged down by Russia gate another fake
garbage and the impeachment Ukraine gate
all lies by the way and so I'm like this
guy's got to get a clean shot he's got
to get a 20 20. he's got he's got to win
and then he's got to be given an
opportunity but now I'm not feeling it I
mean not only does he not have the
energy that made me laugh he's not
talking about the policy stuff either
it's like you got to give me one or the
other I want both Rhonda Sanders
honestly he gives me policy but he's not
a funny guy I mean I don't think Milo
was wrong when he said he had the
Charisma of something off-putting like
when you reach to grab something and
accidentally touch a wet sponge you know
it was very clever and funny of Milo to
say and I really do like Ronda santis in
terms of his governorship and his policy
but he he doesn't have that trumpian
energy no I think his biggest selling
point is that he has this All-American
family right I mean if you saw uh Casey
desantis's second inauguration dress you
know what I'm talking about the gold one
she is dressing like a first lady even
some of her her style choices reflect
Melania Trump they are presenting as
this young uh professional and also
they've got the family and she just went
through breast cancer they have this
sort of relatable morality to their
family that you would want to Rally
around it's not that the Trump family is
bad in any way but it's similar it
reminds me of the comparison to JFK are
obvious because he also had their family
wasn't he the youngest president in the
nation's history I think Ron DeSantis
evokes that idea that there's sort of a
fresher breath there or a fresher of
breath air close enough oh my gosh uh a
breath of fresh air in Republican
politics that we haven't had especially
since we know our Republican leaders
tend to be older to put I'm not saying
this is not like me throwing my weight
behind to Santa's but I do think his
appeal is very aesthetic it's that he
has these children's has he has this
classy wife that they're trying to sort
of show he is one of many families in
America you know it was Teddy Roosevelt
was the youngest person ever become
president after uh William McKinley was
assassinated but Kennedy was the
youngest to get elected president up to
he's 43 and that's the Santa's age at
the moment yeah
I I like what he did with Florida that I
mean when all I'm looking at right now
is the way that people got shut down
businesses got shut down people lost
their jobs their livelihoods had to wear
dirty masks send their kids to school
with dirty masks and uh the Santa's just
like not in Florida man so that that
gives me hope that like you're gonna
crap on the world not in America man I
get that vibe from Rona Santos but he's
still like untested on the global
political stage and I don't want to go
into some dumb War because of emotions I
don't know him I gotta know him to know
that and please watch him debate neither
one of them seem to have like a fire
behind their campaign when Trump
initially announced the first time there
was no stopping what was happening and I
don't feel that this time and I don't
feel it from DeSantis either Tooth Fairy
hasn't announced we need a Donald Trump
to stand up and give the middle finger
to everybody once again this is what
people like they liked that you might
not have agreed with them you might have
actually said oh that's a little rough
but you knew that if Donald Trump was
going to sit down in front of Vladimir
Putin he was going to spit on the floor
and say F you you're not getting it he
wasn't going to apologize eyes and go on
a tour around the world saying I'm sorry
who's going to say screw off and if I
have to I'll blow you up not that he
really would you know but that but as
Trump said that five percent chance you
know Vidor Putin this is the crazy thing
they they talk about uh Russia and
Ukraine what provoked Russia and I'm
seeing these analysis these reports that
a lot of it happened to be under Trump
and because of trump and I'm like gee
that's really weird that Vladimir Putin
was being provoked and didn't attack and
it wasn't until Joe Biden got in that he
started amassing troops on the border
and preparing for an assault because he
knew that that Joe Biden was too weak to
do anything about it but Donald Trump's
a scary dude so when you when he was up
on stage in front of the American people
and you're expecting someone to to be
terrified of cancel culture and and
censorship and the media and he calls
people fat pigs and horse face
I mean I think a lot of Americans were
like that's that's the president that's
the shock that puts him on the stage but
it's not a sustainable presidential
method to be like idiot dumbass horse
face stupid over there hey don't forget
all right all right you're still an
idiot he's still a dumbass he's still a
horse don't you think that's how the
American public feels though they wish
someone would say these yes at least at
least say it maybe once if you think it
but he needs a mess I mean I'm
obsessively thinking about graphene as
we're talking you need something in a
message about what are we going to do as
people how are we going to build this
country better he wants to do it but how
are we going to do it Donald I'm asking
you specifically I think if you get into
graphene man and you totally understand
that we can pull the carbon out of the
air and become like World leading
industrialization uh that you would do
it that you might win you might actually
win the presidency on that message
that's what you were just saying
basically Kingsley that that Trump needs
to get back to that messaging of
economic populism that people really
liked definitely yeah and to your point
Tim just about how people love that he's
that fighter and that middle finger in
your face guy I I really think back to
like the Michael Moore movie where he
said You Know The Enemy of My Enemy is
my friend and that's really what it's
all about I think for a lot of the
conservative base when it comes to Trump
right we see that the FBI
um the IRS the mainstream media all
these organizations that hate us they
hate Donald Trump and he's who they fear
the most so I think for me you know he's
my friend that's my guy and not just
that you know as much as in the past
I've certainly been critical of Trump's
over-the-top Brash demeanor as it were
the American people knew that it wasn't
directed at them that he was standing in
front of the American people the working
class looking at the establishment and
the elites and saying it to their faces
people like Nancy Pelosi with her what
did she have like 300 400 of ice cream
in her freezer or some ridiculous number
she like showed off she's like look at
how my ice cream I have so much and
Donald Trump was you you got the
American people looking at this deep
corruption Congress approved writing
all-time lows they don't care they do
these Omnibus this Omnibus build garbage
and then Donald Trump walks out of it
walks up walks out of the crowd of
Elites and says all these people out
here y'all are right turns around gives
them all the middle finger and that
feels good to have someone finally do
that that was Chappelle's joke right he
came out of the house and was like we're
corrupt I know because I benefit from it
but then he went back in and America's
still like that's the guy I mean I I
think it's undeniable that he has an
amazing uh fan base in the American
public especially in states that feel
like they weren't represented before I
just he needs to breathe life into his
campaign and I'm not sure
trying to make a friend of me out of Ron
DeSantis is the way to go well look
there's there there's going to be a
primary so it's going to get dirty and
we'll and we'll see all the e drama
around it's going to be interesting as
we get more and more into a world of
Voters who grew up online we're going to
see more of this develop thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time